make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into the
immortal Hulk and a lot of you guys have
been asking for this this is because we
really kind of let this most recent
volume finish before we went back in and
covered it so we're kind of covering the
whole volume now writes this the
traditional volume volume type stories
it that we do kind of off and on you
know sometimes we do single issue
sometimes we do whole volumes it kind of
depends on how I feel about it but this
story is particularly interesting right
because I wouldn't say that this takes a
break away from the kind of angels and
demons devil you know one below all sort
of situation that we've had before this
really shines the light more on the
direction that the immortal Hulk is
going in at least for right now anyway
right like really focuses more on Banner
and focuses on the the immortal Hulk and
the reason why that's important is
because al Ewing really likes to kind of
start his stories off with a bang right
for example for those of you guys who
read Ultimates by al Ewing the first
three arc was turning Galactus in the
lowlife ring right so it was like
totally shifting Galactus up and it was
like okay that's cool right and then you
start to go into the more of like the
meat and potatoes let's build this up
let's kind of focus on the character
with the ultimate I would go as far as
to say that was a series of comics that
was only ever going to be short-lived
right because when you look at it a lot
of people weren't really buying it so it
wasn't really like it was gonna be
lasting for like 100 issues or something
on those lines and the other thing is to
kind of build on stuff right so with the
Incredible Hulk really what the Hulk
himself he's like a timeless character
right so al Ewing's Run would last a lot
longer than it would with the ultimate
since that's why you see him really
delving a little more into the human
side of things but to kind of get into
this tried to kind of have this
discussion what this does is it
initially focuses on essentially Bruce
Banner inciting revolution and it's kind
of cool right you know cuz what he does
here is he kind of makes the speech to
humanity more or less kind of like this
this sort of pirate speech where he
basically is in a location of course we
know it's in shadow base and even says
he's in shadow base but doesn't really
tell anybody where he is right he's just
kind of like this is a place that I'm at
and they kind of broadcast this message
now the overall message is sort of
peppered in over the course of this
story but we can kind of consolidate it
all at the beginning of this video and
it's one of the coolest things right
because basically what he says is the
world that we live in the human world as
you guys call it basically sucks and
this is kind of a big moment because
what it is is as Bruce Banner kind of
walking away from like the human side of
themselves
and kind of focusing on the fact that he
is in fact a Hulk right that's what he
is you know he and the Incredible Hulk
are part and parcel and it's interesting
to see that because we've always kind of
seen this this scenario where Bruce
Banner hates the Incredible Hulk side of
himself right but in this instance he's
kind of welcoming it in right he's kind
of you know being like this is who I am
now but what he does is he really kind
of illustrates this is an organization
that was funded by the federal
government with a budget of 1.2 billion
dollars and that money could have gone
to education that money could have gone
to any number of things that could have
made the world a better place but
instead the government decided to use
that money for to basically track me
down and track down people like me and
then try to harvest me and make other
versions of me for their own personal
use right to basically use gamma
radiation to make their own personal
army and then he starts to go into these
interesting scenarios right he starts to
talk about how what you have in in the
United States is a moment is basically a
kind of system that exists where you
have exceedingly vastly no exceedingly
powerful people amassing great
quantities of wealth for themselves and
then just kind of leaving leaving
everybody else out there to you know
sort of high and dry but the funny thing
about this is he doesn't really let the
American people get away with playing
the victim right you know where where
the American people would look at this
and they would shake their head and nod
their head and say yeah he's right man
they really are letting us know there
really are screwing us over instead he
kind of turns a table on them and then
so it's okay so like what have you done
about it
right like if this is the kind of
country you live in then what have you
done to fix it and then that's when you
hear crickets
right that's what do you see empty
pockets because it's kind of like well I
mean you know it's it's you know like
you guys have all these complaints about
how like Amazon never pays taxes so why
are you still buying products off the
website right like it's one of these
things where he kind of points the
finger at people and says you know look
like the issue that you have is doing
things changes things doing nothing
keeps things exactly as they are but
you're lazy you're comfortable right and
because you're comfortable you don't
really see a reason to change things you
don't want to change the status quo
because it means life would be
uncomfortable so all you're gonna do is
reduce yourself to posting on Reddit
formed or Vimeo making reddit posts and
doing Twitter hashtags and that's the
extent of your involvement now from
there it jumps into a conversation he
has with amadeus cho and the response
this was kind of cool about this is
while the message of Bruce Banner is one
where it's kind of like okay this is a
little heavy-handed basically telling
the American people if you want to
change things then quit being lazy and
do something about it they do right they
they start to respond and that's really
kind of what you needed right it's you
kind of needed a scenario where you
needed somebody to get out there and
give people a swift kick in the ass
right
be like you're the source of your own
problems everything wrong with the
country comes down to you right you're
the one that votes for people you're the
one that buys companies products it
really is all your fault so if you want
to change things do something about it
and people are people are responding
right and it's kind of a cool thing
because you know initially amadeus cho
is kind of like okay i'm on the fence
about this a little bit right like i'm
on the fence about this whole thing
because i don't really know how i feel
about this one what you're doing is
resonating with people but - you're
inciting revolution and usually whenever
people revolt people get stupid right
because people if people revolt based on
their emotions in the moment right like
this is bad so let's do something about
it okay cool let's execute the Kings
he's kind of like people don't people
are highly emotional individuals right
when people get highly emotional logic
goes out the window and so yes you're
getting people to act but you're getting
them to act emotionally you're not
giving them the act logically and
reasonably but at the end of the day
that doesn't really seem to be a concern
why you basically have people who are
just kind of spray-painting on walls we
believe in Bruce Banner you have this
idea of people who are basically using
these outfits you know that basically
helps them to kind of deal with teargas
who are yelling like you know like Hulk
smash you know and and then just like
grabbing tear gas canisters throwing
them back at the government's that
launch them at them in the first place
you have like a full-scale revolt on
your hands but one of the things that
you see here you know in addition to
rioting is you also see what's called
rocks news now rocks news is where we
start to really get into the the kind of
meat and potatoes of this right because
you've got like DJs right these these
sort of these sort of political pundits
who are like hey everyone we should all
do something and bye-bye all of us I
mean you I'm just gonna stay here behind
my radio and just talk you know that's
what I'm going to do you know and it's
and it's interesting because you kind of
keep getting like these rocks news blips
right you know these these rocks on News
Corporation's is these those rocks on
things where it's always this idea of
like did the countries go into pot
things are going to pieces the Hulk is
bad you know someone and so forth
everything's kind of going nuts and so
what you end up having is you end up
having Amadeus Cho kind of almost sort
of washes his hands and says look man I
get where you're coming from I get what
you're trying to do but this kind of
situation never really ends well and
then name with a submariner steps in
right he was just kind of there over
hearing things and Bruce Banner was
aware of his presence it was really kind
of like thanks man for not stepping up
here well amadeus cho is here because he
would assume that we're working together
and you end up getting you know Namor
who kind of offers a couple bits of
wisdom but we don't really get an exact
specification for what that is basically
what we get is we end up getting Bruce
Banner basically saying like you know if
these companies
and this wall around us doesn't really
want to change right if these companies
can do what they can do because there's
no consequences right because they
purchase politicians they kind of you
know pay those politicians to ensure
nothing really happens because you guys
aren't gonna do anything then we will
right like then basically I'm going I'm
gonna start like the first strike in a
war right it's basically the Hulk
revolution you know The Incredible Hulk
initiates a revolt in the United States
and it's kind of crazy because when all
that happens then suddenly you switch
over to Dario Agron now the reason why i
dial Agra's doing this and this is kind
of an important thing Dario agar was
introduced as part of Jason Aaron's run
basically on Thor try four got a thunder
issue number 19 I think it was and Dario
agar is the head of he's the CEO of
rocks on oil rocks on corporation really
is it technically it's Roxxon Energy
Corp but they're they're a multinational
company right and they're about as
crooked as it gets if it's if it's
slavery if it's drugs if it's anything
illegal right purging you're buying
politicians if it's anything illegal
Roxxon likely has their hand in it and
so what you get here is this sort of
coalescing of themes right you basically
got the shadow base group who are
essentially like okay look you know
we're gonna send Bruce Banner in but one
of the things to understand about
translocation essentially teleportation
is that it's a very risky maneuver right
like it might be easy for Reed Richards
because he's super smart but for the
rest of us it can be kind of difficult
right so the fear is that when Bruce
Banner teleports to this location this
rocks on location where he's gonna
launch his first strike that he could
end up being teleported there is just a
giant amorphous blob of like bones and
organs and blood and veins and muscle
and all that kind of stuff or he might
make it there in one piece there's no
way to really know we just gotta give it
a shot and find out and hopefully you
make it there now because of the fact
that the immortal Hulk is immortal he
would come back right he would be fun
but like at the end of the day even if
you could heal from all that you don't
want to go through it because it would
suck at the same time you have Dario
Agra really sort of putting off what's
really is this overconfidence right this
idea that we don't really need to worry
about whatever strike Bruce Banner is
gonna do because the forces we have the
berserkers are more than capable of
being able to withstand the Hulk now
where you have Dario Agra who's talking
to his guy you know one of us one of his
guys Higgins and he's kind of like I'm
not really worried about this you know
I'm not really worried about whatever it
is a hoax gonna do whatever attack he
launches it's not gonna matter
everything's gonna be fine the immortal
Hulk shows up here and just starts
crushing all these berserkers and I
don't even mean by like a little bit I
mean by like
like he's just absolutely you know
decimating these guys you know out there
in in Oregon and the reason why that
matters is because once Dario agar is
being told what's going on his response
is what did you say and that's what we
end up learning the significance of all
this that in Oregon that when it when it
comes to Roxxon Oil Corporation and in
order for them to kind of maintain the
image that they have which is a positive
one they essentially influence all forms
of media right they influence about
television they influence newspapers the
whole nine yards in terms of their own
their own newspapers they release their
own television shows their you know
radio jockeys that are kind of bought
and paid for different things like that
now at the end of the day it still
doesn't really matter right like the job
of the average person is to consider
multiple sources of information not just
one but it is kind of a cool thing
because it means that Roxxon has their
hands in a lot of propaganda out there
and and really the the strike or the the
center in Oregon is really kind of the
main hub of it all that's where all the
servers are that's where all the
information gets sent out there from and
so because of that it's a terrifying
prospect for for Roxxon because what it
means is that Bruce Banner is true to
his work that he's basically bringing
the entire institution crashing down
right that's the whole idea it's a kind
of insight revolt among people and bring
the entire institution crashing down
around all of them and so with that
being the case well it doesn't really
mean like a full and total you know
destruction of the United States right
he's not really saying like let's tear
down the government list list do those
kind of yell so on and so forth but the
result is that it's kind of leading to
you know the American people in a lot of
ways sort of kind of coming out and say
yes we're tired of everything being the
way that it is and so with that being
the case
darío edgar in turn takes the smart
approach and this is the smartest thing
that he could have done right if the
entire idea behind this revolt more or
less rests on the shoulders of how
people perceive Bruce Banner in the
Incredible Hulk that he's kind of a
rallying point didn't take away their
reason to believe that right like at the
end of the day people believe what they
want to believe but people are also
easily swayed and they're easily
manipulated right that's kind of how
people arts not to sound too cynical
about it but people are very intelligent
when they operate in groups and so
because of that is one of these things
where he's like well then let's let's
ship the whole thing and turn it into a
smear campaign against the immortal Hulk
that's what we need to do is basically
tarnish the guy's name so nobody will
really believe in him right if people
knows it's it's if people don't believe
in him then nobody will have a reason to
follow him and so this comes in a
multitude of different ways one of the
first people to get hit is Jackie McGee
now if you guys recall Jackie McGee was
the one who was really following the
immortal Hulk
in terms of all the events that were
going on and kind of documenting them
right so she could write a paper on it
and what's happening here is when she's
writing this this you know writing about
this kind of revolt that's going on this
she writes and you know not from a
neutral perspective of like this is a
thing that's happening you know the who
what when where why and how
instead she's doing what most members of
the media do which is writing it from a
after a perspective words how I see it
right so she's writing it like you know
we are being affected and this is
bothering us and we should you know we
you know should we revolt and different
things like that when in reality the
media is not supposed to really be part
of society it's supposed to be removed
from society in that way of here is a
here's an objective depiction of what's
going on not a hey guys look at what's
happening that's affecting all of us
right it's not really supposed to tie
into the emotional element of people now
tying it into people's emotions makes
them want to read about you and watch
you which is why you see things
unfolding that way but with regards to
what Jackie's doing it's kind of flying
in the face of what the News Corporation
what they're supposed to be doing so
it's not really Dario agar kind of
intervening and it is but but not
necessarily the other way in which he
intervenes is by basically stepping up
and releasing these kind of monsters
into into the City of Phoenix Arizona
and the reason why is because when this
happens of course he knows that right
off the bat as soon as that takes place
the EM mortal Hulk and all of them are
going to respond and the reason why he
knows that is that because when you have
shadow base who runs up on Bruce Banner
says hey man like there's these monsters
that showed up in in in Phoenix we have
to respond their knees question is why
and it's like well because the Avengers
are off planet which they are third year
they were dealing with star brand at the
time the Fantastic Four are off doing
their thing tried the x-men are totally
tied up in krakoa they are literally not
gonna worry about it too much the
champions are currently on the East
Coast with no real fast mode of travel
to get there right so it would take them
hours to arrive on the scene and the
ages of Atlas suck and so because of
that it's kind of like all right like no
one no one can respond except for us
Dario agar knew this right because he
had people in different locations that
were feeding him this information and so
launching this attack in in Phoenix
Arizona instead of like San Francisco or
Seattle or New York or something along
those lines or even in the middle of the
United States rights like Kansas or in
Missouri or something like that what
this basically meant is that it presents
a scenario where they're the only ones
that can really get there in time enter
the actual main campaign itself that
when the immortal Hulk teleports in
suddenly he's swallowed by one of the
monsters now this is where you end up
getting the really smart played by da
really really
this is where you really kind of learned
that as a CEO he's exceedingly effective
right because when this goes down he's
basically swallowed by this monster the
the immortal Hulk is swallowed by this
monster and set upon by like all these
you know different things in there these
these you know bugs and and different
you know organisms and and so on and so
forth and and you know what have you but
well that's also going on you've got the
rest of the of the immortal Hulk team
who are essentially showing up and
facing off against these various forces
and so on and it's cool to see right you
got Rick Jones who really is more of
like a gamma level God now I don't
really know what's going on with him
he's kind of resurrected from the dead
so I guess he's partially alive a
partially dad I'm not really sure but
he's like floating around right like he
looks like Moloch you a man or like to
beyond or like dr. Manhattan it's kind
of what he looks like right like just
showing up using like telekinetic and
telepathic gamma powers and like
destroying things and so on and so what
it looks kind of cool you've also got
doc Samson you've got you've got red
harpy or Betty Ross here but the other
thing about this is again you get the
absorbing pressure creel and that's one
of the things that I've been talking
about guys crusher creel and this is
important you guys understand crusher
creel is underrated and it's so good to
see somebody using him right like it's
so good to see somebody using crusher
creel in an interesting way he's really
get a whole lot of screen time here
which is fine you know I mean the story
kinda revolves around a lot of different
characters not just him but crusher
creel is probably one of the most
underappreciated and most dangerous
characters in all of Marvel Comics right
like let let let Wolverines Adam let his
skin get blown off his bones and then
let crusher creel walk up to him and
just touch it and then absorb adamantium
and become adamantium regardless do you
basically get alpha flight showing up
here right now you get the forces of
Parkin and an titania you get absorbing
man crusher creel and so it's kind of
kind of cool to see here but at the end
of the day Daario augers not super
concerned about all this he is insofar
as it's like okay like this can kind of
be a little bit of a struggle force but
at the end of the day he's not super
freaking out about it and the reason why
is because where you end up having you
know all these forces who were you know
taking out these these monsters and
they're all done in pretty fast the
immortal Hulk
rips himself out of one of the monsters
and when he does he unleashes all these
smaller monsters all over the entire
city of Phoenix Arizona and that's
exactly what Dario Agger was waiting for
it that's exactly what he was hoping for
that by releasing all these monsters who
in turn are going to start ripping up
you know when killing people throughout
a throughout Phoenix then it's basically
the news which breaks in oh my god man
look at all the stuff that's going on
being the immortal Hulk has unleashed
these monsters across the City of
Phoenix this is his fault we don't know
exactly what's going on here but it's
definitely his fault right and people
will usually always believe the news if
it's what they want to hear and so
because of that it feeds right into what
it is that that Dario Agra shooting for
and then he basically says we have our
final person coming in to discredit the
the immoral whole kind of going towards
this idea of getting rid of the immortal
Hulk and replacing the Hulk with
basically an agent of art of their own
we end up getting Zimny or Xin Xin mu or
whatever it is people call him the
original Hulk he's not he's just like a
criminal from his own world who like
what's called a Hulk at one point right
but like not really that's like seeing
the original Human Torch to Jim Hammond
is is like the Human Torch
not really it's Johnny Storm you know
that's that's really kind of what it is
but nonetheless it's interesting we're
gonna see like a giant furry guy who's
got hypnotic eyes and he's really smart
we're gonna see him fight you know face
off against the immortal Hulk
it's cool I guess but nonetheless guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
Bruce okay I want to give a shout out to
Kyle B David Joseph Ben John h aj Matt
and Jeff are John H lean and mean which
is an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin Asia Joey M Steven Z Austin B
Adam K and Genesis 9 16 remember guys
you can send me messages and I'll run
off whatever your message is at the end
of the video so long there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson comm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]